[Musique]
je viens d'apprendre qu'à trois mois je
crois qu'il y avait une part il n'est
fait en a finalement 3 et si on va
planter le bras de l'un par seconde paye
cet arbre endémique de la réunion
retrouve symboliquement ses racines ici
dans le quartier de bois de nèfles au
collège jules solesse le département de
la réunion et ses partenaires lancent la
première plantation de l'opération wa de
quartier l'objectif étant de replanter
des espèces endémiques de la réunion
dont un tiers est menacée d'extinction
c'est le premier d'une longue série je
le dis à palmiste rouge on va planter
des palmistes rouge attend rouge et en
rouge à bois d'olives de badauds les
boîtes pommes de poires pommes et dans
les boîtes 9 passes cas pas un bois de
la fir plusieurs villages qui porte le
nom de wadah qu'on va planter des bas de
laine des bois de senteur des mao une
vingtaine d'espèces endémiques seront
replantés au sein de ce collège sensible
à leur histoire et à la fragilité de la
biodiversité à la réunion ces collégiens
s'engage pleinement dans cette action
mais plus on commence au conservatoire
et puis c'est aussi par ce biais
impliquer au maximum la population et
collégiens sont nés citoyens de demain
donc si les impliquer dans la
préservation de la biodiversité
exceptionnelle de la réunion on parle du
bois de neige c'est vraiment important
de prendre conscience de la
vulnérabilité de cette espèce si elle
disparaît à la réunion cela veut dire
qu'elle disparaît de la surface de la
terre et donc c'est une grande
responsabilité pour les citoyens du
collège redonner du sens à notre
histoire à celle de nos quartiers tout
en préservant notre biodiversité tels
sont les grands enjeux portés par cette
opération boîte quartier
[Musique]